THE SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETTA. ASHBY, ATKINS.
BECKER. BLAKESPEAR. BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTESI DAILY. DODD.
HAGMAN. GLASER GONZALES GROVE
Ó. JONES. LAYERED LIMÓN MCGUIRE
MENJIVAR. MEN. NEWMAN. WHEN NILO
WHAT YOU'RE ABOUT. BY THE
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO SUHARTO
SKINNER, SMALLER CUEVAS STERN.
NUMBER WE'LL HAVE WIENER WILK. A
QUORUM. QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY, PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELE
GORMAN, AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. AS WE
PRAY THESE DAYS FOR PEACE AND
UNITY IN OUR AREAS OF WORSHIP
AND IN OUR WORLD. WE CONSIDER
THE WORDS OF JUDITH HILL IN
2001. ADVISING US TO WAGE PEACE.
WAGE PEACE WITH YOUR BREATH.
BREATH BREATHE IN FIREMEN AND
REBEL BREATHE OUT WHOLE
BUILDINGS. BREATHE IN TERRORISTS
AND BREATHE OUT SLEEPING
CHILDREN. BREATHE IN CONFUSION.
AND BREATHE OUT MAPLE TREES.
BREATHE IN THE FALLEN. AND
BREATHE OUT LIFELONG FRIENDSHIPS
INTACT. WHICH PIECE ALSO WITH
YOUR LISTENING. HEARING SIRENS
PRAY ALOUD. REMEMBER YOUR TOOLS,
FLOWERS SUITS CLOTHES, PINS,
CLEAN RIVERS. PLAYING MUSIC.
LEARNED THE WORD. THANK YOU IN
THREE LANGUAGES. THINK OF CHAOS
AS DANCING RASPBERRIES. IMAGINE
GRIEF AS THE OUT BREATH OF
BEAUTY. WAGE PEACE. NEVER HAS
THE WORLD SEEMED SO FRESH AND
PRECIOUS. ACT AS IF ARMSTEAD
ISSUE HAS ALREADY ARRIVED. DON'T
WAIT ANOTHER MINUTE. MERCIFUL
GOD. WE TRUST IN YOUR PRESENCE
AS WE ENGAGE THE CHALLENGING
WORK OF WAGING PEACE AND UNITY.
AMEN. MEMBERS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE.
SENATOR LAIRD FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK UNDER PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. GREAT FOR THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I'LL LET ME THANK
THE MAJORITY LEADER FOR LETTING
THE STANDARDIZED TEST TO ANOTHER
CAL POLY. UM I'M PLEASED TO
WELCOME 19, CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO STUDENTS WHO HAVE ONE
INDIVIDUAL OR TEAM AWARDS. HERE
TODAY AND THREE ASSOCIATED
STUDENT UM LEADERS THAT
REPRESENT THE COW POLISH STUDENT
BODY AND THEY ARE JOINED BY COW
BALI'S PRESIDENT, GEOFF
ARMSTRONG, AND I AM HAPPY TO
WELCOME THEM TO THE STATE
SENATE. FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
AREN'T FAMILIAR WITH CAL POLY
ONE OF 23 OF THE CSU CAMPUSES IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO ON CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL COAST. ABOUT HALFWAY
BETWEEN THE AREAS OF THE DODGERS
AND THE GIANTS. THE LOCATION
GIVES STUDENTS ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HANDS ON
RESEARCH, PARTICULARLY
AGRICULTURE, WINEMAKING,
DISTINCTIVE COASTAL ECOSYSTEMS
AND MARINE SCIENCE AND HAS A
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO TECH INDUSTRY
AND CULTURE HUBS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE BAY AREA. AND
THIS GIVES CAL POLY STUDENTS AND
OPPORTUNITY TO DO WORK THAT
MAKES AN IMPACT AROUND THE STATE
AND AROUND THE GLOBE. AH CAL
POLY CONSISTENTLY RECEIVES HIGH
RANKINGS FROM MAJOR PUBLICATIONS
FOR THE PAST 30 YEARS. IT'S BEEN
NAMED THE BEST PUBLIC MASTERS
LEVEL UNIVERSITY IN THE WEST BY
THE U. S NEWS AND WORLD REPORT.
IT'S ACHIEVED A FIVE STAR RATING
ON MONEY MAGAZINE'S 2023 BEST
COLLEGE RANKINGS, ALONG WITH 33
OTHER SCHOOLS. INCLUDING HARVARD
, PRINCETON, YALE AND COLUMBIA.
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
CELEBRATE AND RECOGNIZE THE
INDIVIDUAL ACHIEVEMENTS OF THESE
STUDENTS, AND IT IS ALL IN
DIFFERENT THINGS, THEY WORK IN
THE SIX COLLEGES AT CAL POLY. I
KNOW THAT THE SENATOR FROM THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WELCOMED A
STUDENT THAT IS FROM HER
DISTRICT. THERE IS A STUDENT
FROM SENATOR NEAL OWES DISTRICT
TOGETHER WITH THIS STUDENTS TEAM
. ONE DAY YOU ESPADA DIVISION
TWO WOMEN'S POLO NATIONAL
INTERCOLLEGIATE CHAMPIONSHIP.
THERE'S A STUDENT FROM SENATOR
ALLEN'S DISTRICT, WHO, WITH THE
ROSE FLOAT TEAM RECEIVED THE
CROWN CITY INNOVATOR AWARD. IT
IS A LONG STANDING TRADITION FOR
CAL POLY. THE STUDENTS, FACULTY
LEADERSHIP ALUMS TO PUT TOGETHER
AN AMAZING ROSE. BOTH PARADE
FLOAT EVERY YEAR. THAT IS ONE
AWARDS THROUGH THE YEARS AND HAS
BECOME SUCH AN INSTITUTION
WITHIN THE CAMPUS THAT EVERYBODY
PARTICIPATES. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK GEOFF ARMSTRONG, HIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE FACULTY
OF CAL POLY FOR EDUCATING AND
CREATING SUCH A GROUP OF WINNERS
THAT WE ARE TODAY, SO PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CAL POLY
HERE TODAY. GIVE THEM A WARM
SENATE WELCOME.
OKAY?
MEMBERS IF YOU WANT TO WAIT A
SECOND, YOU'LL BE ABLE TO GET
INTO THE NEXT PICTURES.
NOW IF MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
JOIN THE PICTURE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL OF THE
CAL POLY STUDENTS AND THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON
WITH OUR AGENDA. FOR TODAY,
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON EMOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. ARE
THERE ANY MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS
OR NOTICES. SAYING NONE WILL
MOVE ON TO UNFINISHED. BUSINESS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILL'S SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 952 AND 953. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FILE ITEM NUMBER 74.
SECOND READING FIRST. OKAY?
WE'LL TAKE UP. MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FIREWOOD. TAKE IT SECOND READING
FILE. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 920 SENATE BILL 26
53 85 TO 32 94 3 12 4 84 83 81
MOVING ON TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER 74 SENATOR
WEINER IS PREPARED. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 339 BY SENATOR
WIENER INOCULATING TO
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
WIENER, THE FLORIDA THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. SP
339 IS BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE. AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY ADDED AN URGENCY CLAUSE
NECESSARY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I VOTE NO MEMBERS. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I BROUGHT A GIRL.
ALRIGHT, ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY.
ATKINS. I BECKER AYE,
BLAKESPEAR. BRADFORD. AYE,
CABALLERO. AYE, CORTEZ E. I
DOLLY. ALRIGHT, DODD. HUESO.
AYE, EGGMAN. AYE, GLASER. I
GONZALES I GROVE AYE. ORTHODOX.
ALRIGHT JONES. I LAIRD I LEMON.
AYE, MCGUIRE. I MENTIONED BAR. I
MEN. AYE, NEWMAN. I WHEN.
ALRIGHT, NILO. ALRIGHT, WHAT'S
YOUR BOOK? ALRIGHT PADILLA.
ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT ROTH
RUBIO. I SEE ARTO SKINNER.
ALRIGHT SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. STERN.
I AM BERG. ALRIGHT, WE'LL HAVE
AYE, WIENER. I WELCOME AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY. ALL RIGHT. BLAKESPEAR HI
SMALLER CUEVAS. I 39 NO. ZERO
THE URGENCY. ON THE URGENCY IS
39 NO. ZERO THE MEASURE. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING. FILE ITEM NUMBER 80
SENATOR RUBIO IS PREPARED.
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 536 BY
SENATOR RUBIO AND EQUAL INTO
HORSE RACING. SENATOR RUBIO
RUBIO. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SP 536 VERY
SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL SUPPORT
THE SPORT OF HORSE RACING IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL ADDS THE
DELAWARE HANDICAP TO THE
EXISTING LIST OF AT A STATE
HORSE RACES THAT ARE EXEMPT FROM
CALIFORNIA'S 50TH RACE PER DAY
IMPORTATION LIMIT. THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND PASS WITH
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
SAYING NONE EYES 39 NO. ZERO
MEASURES ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 83. SENATOR
SKINNER. SHE IS PREPARED. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 56 BY SENATOR
SKINNER INEQUITY INTO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS. SENATOR SKINNER. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MADAM. PRESIDENT MEMBERS. SB 56.
CORRECT SOMETHING IN STATE LAW
IN ORDER TO ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA, BERKELEY TO
TRANSFER OWNERSHIP. OF A STUDENT
HOUSING FACILITY CALLED THE
ROACH DALE APARTMENTS TO THE
BERKELEY STUDENT COOPERATIVE
ASSOCIATION. THE BERKELEY
STUDENT COOPERATIVE ASSOCIATION
WAS FOUNDED IN 1933. IT IS THE
OLDEST STUDENT COOPERATIVE IN
THE UNITED STATES. IT, UM
OPERATES 17 HOUSES AND THREE
APARTMENT BUILDINGS IN BERKELEY
HOUSING 1700 STUDENTS, VERY
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING. AND
THE ROAD STILL APARTMENTS WHILE
THEY ARE BUILT ON UNIVERSITY
LAND AND THUS OWNED BY THE
UNIVERSITY, CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE
BEEN OPERATED SINCE THE DAY THEY
OPENED BY THE COOPERATIVE
ASSOCIATION. NOW THE REASON THAT
TRANSFERS NECESSARY IS BECAUSE
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
EARTHQUAKE UPGRADES AND SOME
VERY IMPORTANT WORK DONE. AND IN
ORDER TO FINANCE THAT WORK, IT'S
GOING TO BE MUCH EASIER FOR THE
COOPERATIVE ASSOCIATION OF
FINANCE IT IF THE OWNERSHIP IS
IN THEIR HANDS, THE UNIVERSITY
HAS AGREED TO THIS. THEIR
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. THE
COOPERATIVE ASSOCIATION WANTS IT
. SO UH, THAT'S IT IN A
NUTSHELL. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I TYPICALLY
OPPOSE BILLS SUCH AS THIS THAT
TRANSFER PUBLIC PURCHASED LAND.
WITHOUT A BIDDING PROCESS. I
UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL,
BUT I DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR OF SHE WOULD BE WILLING
TO TAKE A QUESTION. WILL YOU
ACCEPT A QUESTION? YES I WILL
PARTICULAR CASE. I UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S CURRENTLY NONPROFIT
HOUSING AND THE, UH, UNIVERSITY
JUST WANTS TO TRANSFER IT TO AN
OPERATOR THAT WOULD CONTINUE
THAT UM, BUT THERE'S MY
UNDERSTANDING ISN'T IN THE WAY
THE LIE IS WRITTEN TODAY,
THERE'S NOTHING IN THERE THAT
PROTECTS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OR THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS. IF THIS NONPROFIT THE
BERKELEY COOPERATIVE STUDENT
HOUSING PROGRAM DISSOLVES FOR
WHATEVER REASON OR BECOMES
INSOLVENT. UH IS THERE CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT BY CHANCE AND LET
US KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME
PROTECTIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA'S
TAXPAYERS. THANK YOU THROUGH
THROUGH THE PRESIDENT, UM THE
BILL STIPULATES THAT THE, UM.
THE BUILDING THE ROADS STILL
APARTMENTS MUST CONTINUE TO BE
USED FOR AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING. SO THERE IS THAT
PROTECTION. IT CAN'T BE
TRANSFERRED TO ANY OTHER USE. SO
WHILE IN THE REMOTE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE UNIVERSITY STUDENT
COOPERATIVE ASSOCIATION WHO AS I
MENTIONED HAS OPERATED AND
MANAGED THIS PROPERTY SINCE THE
DAY IT OPENED AND WHAT THE
ARRANGEMENT HAS BEEN IS LIKE A
DOLLAR A YEAR LEASE BETWEEN THE
UNIVERSITY AND THE COOPERATIVE
ASSOCIATION. IF FOR SOME REASON,
LIKE YOU POINTED OUT THAT WE'RE
NOT TO OPERATE ANY LONGER OR
EXIST, THE PROPERTY AND THE
BUILDING MUST STILL BE
MAINTAINED AS AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING. OKAY THAT HELPS THANK
YOU, SENATOR GROUP. BROACH DEAL.
SO YOU LIVED THERE? I'M SORRY. I
APOLOGIZE. I THOUGHT YOU SAID
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT FOR LET ME RISE ON
SPEAKING ON THIS. I AM. I'M
REALLY TRYING TO IN THIS NEXT
YEAR TO LOOK AT LEGISLATION
INDIVIDUALLY INSTEAD OF
CUMULATIVELY AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE BILLS THAT I'M WORKING ON. I
THINK THIS BILL IS A GOOD BILL.
YES DO I THINK THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING?
ABSOLUTELY DO I THINK THIS IS A
LOOPHOLE? HOW TO GET THAT MAKE
THAT HAPPEN AND TRANSFER STATE
RESOURCES TO THIS NONPROFIT? YES
UM DO I THINK THAT THERE IS
ENOUGH PROTECTIONS IN THERE?
THAT UH, WILL ALLOW THIS PIECE
OF PROPERTY BE TO BE TRANSFERRED
AND THERE'LL BE AGAIN GUARANTEE
THAT IT'S STILL REMAINS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR STUDENTS
TRYING TO GET AN EDUCATION. YES.
MY ISSUE WITH THIS IS THAT IT
ALL SURROUNDS SEISMIC. EACH ONE
OF US ARE ALMOST ALL OF US IN
THIS ROOM, HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM
WITH SEISMIC AND OUR HOSPITALS.
THEY'RE MAKING DECISIONS TO END
LABOR AND DELIVERY OR CARDIO
CARE OR OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE
OUR CONSTITUENTS SEVERELY
RELIANT, ESPECIALLY IN MY AREA
WHERE I HAVE A HIGH MEDICAL
POPULATION. WE WE DON'T OFFER A
BILL TO OFF RAMP SEISMIC, BUT WE
OFFER A BILL TO OFFER UP. OFFER
UP. UM AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS, WHICH IS STILL A GOOD
REASON TO HAVE THIS BILL. I JUST
I WISH WE WOULD LOOK AT THINGS
THAT ARE AFFECTING ALL OF US IN
THIS IN THIS IN THIS BODY,
ESPECIALLY OUR RURAL HOSPITALS
THAT ARE REALLY STRUGGLING WITH
THEM DISTRESSED FINANCIAL LOW
PAYMENTS, THE LOAN PAYMENTS THAT
WERE THE BRIDGE PAYMENTS. UM
EVERY HOSPITAL THAT ACCEPTS
MEDICAL IN THIS IN OUR STATE,
IT'S A PATHWAY TO BANKRUPTCY.
YOU SPEND A DOLLAR AND YOU MIGHT
GET 70 CENTS BACK. NO BUSINESS
PLAN CAN SURVIVE LIKE THAT. I
THINK WE NEED TO. SERIOUSLY LOOK
AT THE SEISMIC. I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD, BUT
I NEEDED TO POINT OUT THE NOT
THE HYPOCRISY BUT THE
DIFFERENCES OF HOW WE TREAT ONE
INDUSTRY VERSUS ANOTHER INDUSTRY
SUPPORTED THIS BILL IN COMMITTEE
AND I WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL
NOW. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NONE. UH SENATOR
LEHMAN MEMBERS. THIS THIS BILL
IS ACTUALLY MORE PERSONAL THAN I
THOUGHT IT WOULD. BECAUSE I
LIVED IN ROCHDALE WHEN I WAS
THERE, AND I FEEL LIKE ANYONE
WHO HAS LIVED THERE. I LIVED
THERE AS A STUDENT. WHEN I WENT
TO COLLEGE. ANYONE WHO HAS LIVED
THERE KNOWS HOW IMPORTANT THE
ROCKDALE COMMUNITY AND THE
ROCKDALE UM, APARTMENTS SHARED
OUR TO THE STUDENT CAMPUS AND
WHAT THEY MEAN FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, SO I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE THAT THIS IS VERY REAL AND
THAT ANY UPGRADES ARE MUCH
NEEDED. I THINK THAT DECADES
AGO, WE PROBABLY WOULD HAVE SAID
THOSE UPDATES WERE NEEDED THEN,
AND I'M GLAD IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NONE. SENATOR
SKINNER, YOU MAY CONCLUDE AS FOR
YOUR VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. I BROUGHT A GIRL. ALRIGHT,
ARCHULETTA. ALRIGHT ASHBY.
ALRIGHT ATKINS. ALRIGHT BECKER.
ALRIGHT BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT,
BRADFORD. ALRIGHT, CABALLERO.
ALRIGHT CORTESI, DOLLY I DODD
ALRIGHT DO THAT SO I ADMIN.
ALRIGHT GLASER GONZALES.
ALRIGHT, GROVE. ALL RIGHT, TODD
Ó. JONES. AYE, LAIRD. LIMÓN
MCGUIRE MENJIVAR. I MEN I NEWMAN
I WHEN NILO. I OR CHILD BOOK?
ALL RIGHT BY THE PORTANTINO AYE,
WRATH. RUBIO I SEE YOUR TOE. I
SKINNER ALRIGHT. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS STERN. I AM BERG.
ALRIGHT, WE'LL HAVE AYE, WIENER.
I WELCOME. ALL RIGHT. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSOLUTE AH. I 39 NOS.
ZERO. THE MEASURES ADOPTED
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 85
SENATOR NEWMAN. HE HAS PREPARED.
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 347 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN INOCULATING
TEACHER CREDENTIAL, SENATOR
NEWMAN. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THE
COMMISSION AND TEACHER
CREDENTIALING RECENTLY ADOPTED
PROPOSED REGULATIONS TO
ESTABLISH THE PK THREE
SPECIALIST INSTRUCTION
CREDENTIAL, WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
AUTHORIZE SERVICE AND
PREKINDERGARTEN THROUGH GRADE
THREE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
PRESCHOOL AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS. EXISTING
LAW AUTHORIZES THE COMMISSIONER,
TEACHER CREDENTIALING TO ISSUE
CREDENTIALS FOR TEACHING
SPECIALTIES, INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. SP 347 SIMPLY
ACKNOWLEDGES IN STATUTE THAT THE
COMMISSIONER TEACHER CREDENTIALS
JURISDICTION RESTRICTION NOW
INCLUDES THE AWARDING OF
CREDENTIALS FOR PRESCHOOL AS
WELL AS FOR KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
GRADE 12 MEASURES SIMPLY CLEANS
UP THE ED CODE TO REFLECT THE
UPDATED CIRCUMSTANCES FOR EC AND
DOES NOT CREATE ANY NEW
CREDENTIALING BURDENS ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? IF YOU'RE
DISCUSSING OR DEBATING DEBATING
ANYTHING ELSE, PLEASE GO OFF THE
FLOOR, SO IT'S NOT SO NOISY. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? SAYING NONE. THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROYAL
CALLERS OR ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SAYING NONE EYES 39 NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURES ADOPTED MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 87. SENATOR
NEWMAN. PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
552 BY SENATOR NEWMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY,
SENATOR NEWMAN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT RISE TO PRESENT SP 552
, WHICH PROVIDES TECHNICAL CLEAN
UP TO THE 2017 REVISION OF THE
CALIFORNIA SWIMMING POOLS SAFETY
ACT, A MEASURE WHICH I CARRIED,
WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW BY
THEN GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN,
ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. TRYING TO
REMAINS ONE OF THE LEADING
CAUSES OF DEATH FOR CHILDREN
AGED 14 AND YOUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA, WITH ROUGHLY 75% OF
ALL FATAL CHILDHOOD DROWNINGS,
OCCURRING AT HOME SCHOOLS OR
INSPIRES TO HELP BETTER PREVENT
SUCH TRAGEDIES. AS BEFORE FOR
TWO OF 2017 INCREASED THE NUMBER
OF REQUIRED SAFETY FEATURES AT
RESIDENTIAL POOLS FROM 1 TO 2
AND INSTITUTED NEW POOL
INSPECTION REQUIREMENTS FOR REAL
ESTATE INSPECTORS. SP FIVE I TWO
ADDRESSES TO TECHNICAL
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES, INCLUDING
A CLARIFICATION ON THE ROLE OF
HOME INSPECTORS AND CLOSING A
LOOPHOLE IN THE TWO STEPS SAFETY
DEVICE REQUIREMENT, THEREBY
ENSURING THAT THESE LIFE SAVING
FEATURES ARE PROPERLY EMPLOYED
TO MOST EFFECTIVELY PREVENT
CHILDHOOD DEATHS AND INJURIES.
TWO YEARS AGO, I WAS PLEASED TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS ON SB 855,
WHICH CLEARLY PROBABLY PROGRAM
TO COLLECT, IMPROVE DATA
COLLECTION ON CHILDHOOD
DROWNINGS IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS BILL, AND I APPRECIATE
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THIS
MEASURE MAY IMPACT THAT WORK. I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM ONCE AGAIN TO TIGHTEN UP
THE LANGUAGE AND ENSURE THEIR
CONCERNS ARE FULLY ADDRESSED. AS
YOU WORK OUR WAY TOWARD THE
FINAL VERSION OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECT THE ASTRA I
VOTE TODAY. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM DISCUSSION? SENATOR DOLLY
YES, QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR,
PLEASE. WOULD YOU TAKE A
QUESTION? SENATOR NEWMAN? YES,
PLEASE. I JUST WOULD LIKE SOME
CLARIFICATION IN OUR RURAL
DISTRICT. WE HAVE SEVERAL PUBLIC
POOLS THAT ARE ON THE BORDERLINE
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO SUSTAINED.
WE DO FUNDRAISERS AND ALL KINDS
OF THINGS TO KEEP THEM OPEN. AND
IN OUR ANALYSIS HERE, THE MANUAL
VERSUS AUTOMATIC POOL COVER.
WOULD BE AN ISSUE BECAUSE THOSE
ARE VERY EXPENSIVE WHERE WE HAVE
MANUALLY. WE'RE DOING IT. SO
COULD YOU MAYBE TOUCH ON THAT. I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE
SOME AMENDMENTS THAT JUST WANT
TO BE CLEAR CLARIFICATION,
TAKING ACTUALLY REVERT BACK WILL
NO LONGER REQUIRE THAT CHANGE.
AND SO THAT WAS A DRAFTING
ERROR, SO THE FINAL VERSION WILL
NOT INCLUDE A MANDATE FOR AN
AUTOMATED POOL COVER. THANK YOU.
THEN I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NONE. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I, ALVARADO GIL.
ALRIGHT, ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY.
I. ATKINS. BECKER. ALRIGHT
BLAKESPEAR. ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. ALRIGHT CORTESI
DAILY. ALRIGHT, DODD. AYE,
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALES GROVE.
I ORDERED Ó. JONES HIGH, LAIRD.
LIMÓN MCGUIRE ALRIGHT, MENJIVAR.
ALL RIGHT, MAN. NEWMAN. ALRIGHT
WHEN I NILO I WANT YOUR BOOK. BY
THE ALRIGHT PORTANTINO. HI, ROB.
RUBIO. I SEE OUR TOE. AYE,
SKINNER. ALRIGHT SMALLER CUEVAS
STERN. ALRIGHT, AMBER. I WILL
HAVE HI WIENER. ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME, AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS. LEMON.
AYE. SMALLER QUIVERS. I 38 NO.
ZERO. THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 89
SENATOR PORTANTINO HE HAS
PREPARED. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX OR SEVEN BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO INOCULATED TO CONTROL
SUBSTANCES, SENATOR PORTANTINO
THAT PORTANTINO. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, SP 67
SIMPLY HAS PRESCRIBERS OF A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE CONTAINING
AN OPIOID TO DISCUSS THE RISK
AND DANGERS OF OPIOIDS AND
OPIOID ADDICTION TO THEIR
PATIENTS. EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
A PRESCRIBER TO DISCUSS SPECIFIC
INFORMATION WITH THEIR PATIENTS
ONLY. REQUIRES THEM TO DO SO
WHEN THEY CONSULT WIND
CONSULTING A MINOR PRESCRIBERS
MAY DISCUSS DETAILS ABOUT
DESCRIPT PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS
WITH THE MINOR THE MINOR'S
PARENTS OR GARDENING OR OTHER
ADULT AUTHORIZED TO THE MINERS
MEDICAL TREATMENT, ACCORDING TO
THE CDC AND PREVENTION. MORE
THAN 1. MILLION PEOPLE HAVE DIED
SINCE 19 8 99 FROM DRUG
OVERDOSES, CURRENTLY ABOUT 75%
OF ALL OVERDOSE DEATHS INVOLVED
AN OPIOID AND IN RECENT YEARS,
OPIOID RELATED OVERDOSE DEATHS
HAVE CONTINUED TO INCREASE FOR
BOTH PRESCRIPTION AND
NONPRESCRIPTION OVER OPIOIDS.
HOWEVER OVERDOSES ARE NOT
EXCLUSIVE TO MINORS. SO BY
EXPANDING THE PRESCRIBERS
RESPONSIBILITY TO DISCUSS
SPECIFIC INFORMATION WITH ALL
PATIENTS WE THINK WILL HAVE
BETTER, HEALTHIER OUTCOMES AND
BETTER AND LESS INCIDENCES OF
OVER OVERDOSES WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SAYING NONE. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
SAYING NONE. I 38 NO. ZERO. THE
MEASURE IS ADOPTED. WE'VE GOT TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 91. SENATOR
GROVE. SHE IS PREPARED. PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 97 BY SENATOR GROWTH
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AWARENESS MONTH THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SCR 97, WHICH
COMMEMORATES JANUARY 2024 AS
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AWARENESS
MONTH. I'D LIKE TO THANK THIS
BODY. EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO PASS
MEANINGFUL, UH, ACTION AND
LEGISLATION ADDRESSING THESE
HORRIFIC ACTS OF CHILD SEX
TRAFFICKING LAST YEAR BY MAKING
A SERIOUS FELONY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AS WE ALL KNOW,
THERE IS STILL SIGNIFICANT WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE, AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS ARE PROTECTED FROM
THIS HEINOUS CRIME. I CAN'T HELP
BUT THINK BACK AND TALK ABOUT
THE, UM THE PERSONAL TESTIMONIES
OF THOSE LIVED EXPERIENCES BY
SURVIVORS. DESPERATE SKINS.
JENNA MCKAY, THOSE FROM CASH.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND SOME
BRIANNA MOSLEY AND SO MANY
OTHERS THAT SHARED THEIR LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF THIS HORRIFIC,
DARK UNDERWORLD ON JANUARY 11TH
PEOPLE ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND
ACROSS THIS STATE WHERE BLUE IN
HONOR OF NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING DAY IN HOPES TO
BRING IN MORE AWARENESS TO THE
MOST LUCRATIVE ONE OF THE MOST
LUCRATIVE CRIMES IN THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE UNFORTUNATE
DISTINCTION OF BEING RANKED
NUMBER ONE FOR THE MOST TIPS
CALLED INTO THE NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HOTLINE AND BECAUSE
OF THIS LOCAL, STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
CONTINUE TO WORK TIRELESSLY TO
END HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE. AS
A LEGISLATIVE BODY. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO COME TOGETHER TO
PROMOTE AWARENESS, EDUCATE
OURSELVES AND OUR LOVED ONES AND
THREW SCR 97. WE ARE DECLARING
THAT OUR STATE IS COMMITTED TO
COMBATING THIS MODERN DAY
SLAVERY WHILE OFFERING SUPPORT
TO SURVIVORS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS RESOLUTION TO GIVE A VOICE
TO THE THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS THAT
HAVE SUFFERED FROM THIS HORRIFIC
ABUSE AND WE GOTTA FIGHT
CONTINUOUSLY TO PROTECT VICTIMS,
STRENGTHEN PREVENTION AND
EDUCATION AND STOP BUYING AND
SELLING HUMAN BEINGS AGAIN FROM
THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART. I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS FLOOR TO GET
THAT BILL OFF OF THIS FLOOR AND
INTO THE ASSEMBLY'S HANDS AND
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S DESK ON
SEPTEMBER 25TH THAT WAS A HUGE
SUCCESS FOR OUR STATE AND MOSTLY
FOR OUR CHILDREN, AND I COULDN'T
HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT ALL MY
SENATE COLLEAGUES, SO THANK YOU.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS ARE
RISING STRONG SUPPORT OF SCR 97.
THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE TO THE
BLACK CAUCUS FOR ALL COMMUNITIES
OF CALIFORNIA, BUT ESPECIALLY
THE BLACK COMMUNITIES. AS I'VE
MENTIONED BEFORE ON THIS FLOOR,
ACCORDING TO A 2020
CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS
REPORT 40% OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS ARE IDENTIFIED AS BLACK
WOMEN. LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
40% OF THOSE ENTERED IDENTIFIED
AS BEING TRAFFICKED OR BLACK
WOMEN. PERPETRATORS WHO WERE
INTERVIEWED ADMITTED BELIEVING
THAT TRAFFICKING BLACK WOMEN
WOULD LAND THEM LESS TIME IN
JAIL THAN TRAFFICKING. WHITE
WOMEN HAVE CAUGHT THIS IS A
CRISIS THAT IS HARMFUL FOR ALL
WOMEN, BUT ESPECIALLY FOR BLACK
GIRLS, WHO ARE OFTEN UNFAIRLY
VIEWED AS NEEDING LESS SUPPORT
AND LESS PROTECTION THAN THEIR
WHITE COUNTERPARTS. AND THERE
ARE OFTEN CATEGORY CATEGORIZED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AS RUNAWAYS
OR CRIMINALS THEMSELVES RATHER
THAN VICTIMS. IN L. A COUNTY. AN
EXAMPLE OF 92% OF THE GIRLS IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM,
IDENTIFIED AS VICTIMS OF SEX
TRAFFICKING ARE BLACK, YET THEY
ARE IDENTIFIED AS JUVENILE
PROSTITUTES, AND WE ALL KNOW A
JUVENILE CANNOT CONSENT TO SEX,
LET ALONE SELL IT. THOSE WHO ARE
NOT ARRESTED, OFTEN RECEIVED
LITTLE OR NO ATTENTION TO THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE MISSING OR
BEING TRAFFICKING. IT IS DUE TO
THIS GREAT DISPARITY THAT LED ME
TO AUTHOR LAST YEAR, THE EBONY
ALERT. THAT CONTINUED TO SHOW
TWO DISPARATE TREATMENT THAT
BLACK WOMEN AND GIRLS CAN NO
LONGER BE IGNORED AND MUST BE
ADDRESSED SADLY TO STATE THAT ON
THE FOURTH DAY OF THIS YEAR, WE
ISSUED THE FIRST EBONY ALERT AND
THIS STATE A BILL THAT HAD ONLY
BEEN IN PLACE FOR FOUR DAYS, AND
IT FOUND THE YOUNG GIRL WHO HAD
BEEN MISSING FOR OVER FIVE DAYS
AND THANK GOD FOR THE AVENUE
ALERT, AND THEY DID ANOTHER ONE
THIS PAST WEEKEND. I WANT TO
COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD. FOR BEING COMMITTED
TO THIS ISSUE AND THANK HER FOR
AUTHORING THIS RESOLUTION AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORT AND ARE
URGED TO SUPPORT FC ARE 97.
SENATOR WAHAB. THANK YOU. I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD EFFORT ON SCR 97
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS MODERN DAY
SLAVERY. WE HAVE HEARD SOME OF
THE STATISTICS ALREADY AND AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF SILICON VALLEY
, IN FACT, IN OUR E R S, THEY
STATE THAT THEY ACTUALLY LOOK
FOR TRAFFICKING VICTIMS. IN
PARTICULAR. YOUNG DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES. IT DOES NOT HAVE A
FACE. HUMAN TRAFFICKING HAS NO
FACE. WE TRAFFIC AND WE SEE THE
FOLKS THAT ARE ACTUALLY DEALING
WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND IT'S
INDIVIDUALS FOR LABOR. AND
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION. IT IS
HAPPENING IN OUR BACKYARDS
THROUGH FORCE, FRAUD AND
COERCION OF VULNERABLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. LARGELY VERY YOUNG
GIRLS, 1213 14. WHILE ANYONE WHO
IS VULNERABLE TO EXPLOITATION
CAN BE TARGETED. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PRIMARILY IMPACTS.
WOMEN AND GIRLS. YOUNG GIRLS AND
WOMEN ARE 57.6% OF FORCED LABOR
VICTIMS AND 99.4% OF SEX
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS, IN FACT,
ALSO AS A KID IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. MANY FOSTER YOUTH AND UP
BEING TRAFFICKED AS WELL. MANY
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES GET
TRAFFICKED. HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS
A VIOLATION OF THE VICTIMS,
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS AND WE MUST
USE ALL THE TOOLS AT OUR
DISPOSAL TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES AGAINST THE RISE OF
THIS HORRIFIC VIOLATION OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S FREEDOMS AND BODILY
AUTONOMY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN EYE. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR TO SCR
97 DECLARING 2024 JANUARY 2024
IS NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AWARENESS MONTH. I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD FOR
INTRODUCING THIS RESOLUTION AND
FOR HER TIRELESS WORK ON THIS
ISSUE, BUT THAT INCLUDES SP 14,
AS WE SAW LAST YEAR THAT
RECOGNIZES HUMAN TRAFFICKING OF
A MINOR AS A SERIOUS FELONY.
WHICH WAS I WAS ALSO VERY PROUD
TO WORK WITH, UM WITH HER AND
ALSO CO AUTHOR AS A LONG TIME
THE VICTIM'S ADVOCATE. MY HEART
GOES OUT TO EVERY PERSON OUT
THERE. UH MY HEART ACHES EVERY
TIME I SIT DOWN WITH THE VICTIM,
ESPECIALLY CHILDREN. THIS
WEEKEND ALONE, I SAT WITH SOME
SURVIVORS. ONE RECOUNTED HER
HORRIFIC EXPERIENCE.
UNFORTUNATELY IT STARTED AT THE
AGE OF FIVE AND SHE WAS PUT IN
THAT SITUATION BY HER MOTHER. SO
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE BECAUSE WE
OFTEN TEND TO THINK THAT IT'S
STRANGERS DURING THE HARM. BUT
IN THIS CASE SHE STARTED AT THE
AGE OF FIVE. SHE DIDN'T GET OUT
UNTIL SHE WAS 16 AND ALL ALONG.
IT WAS HER MOTHER AND HER SISTER
THAT KEPT HER IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES, SO I URGE ALL OF
US TO BE VIGILANT EVEN WHEN IT'S
A PARENT OR A RELATIVE RIGHT
NOW, AS WE MEET HERE TODAY, TOO
MANY CHILDREN AND ADULTS LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA CONTINUED TO BE
FORCED INTO THIS TYPE OF
CIRCUMSTANCE. WE MUST DO MORE TO
IMPROVE AWARENESS. AROUND
PREVENTION, IDENTIFICATION AND
RESPONSE SERVICES ACROSS OUR
STATE. WE MUST DO MORE TO HELP
THOSE IN NEED. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
GROVE, YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE
TO THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. UM YOU KNOW, AT
THE SAME TIME THAT WE WERE
RUNNING SP 14 LAST YEAR, SENATOR
BRADFORD WAS RUNNING THE EBONY
ALERT AND THE INFORMATION THAT
HE PROVIDED IN THE URBAN ALERT
COINCIDED WITH ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAD FROM
HOMELAND SECURITY, THE FBI AND
ALL THE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WE WORKED WITH TO PUT TOGETHER
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT ARE WOMEN AND CHILDREN,
MOSTLY WOMEN AND CHILDREN, SOME
MEN AND BOYS BUT MOSTLY WOMEN
AND CHILDREN FROM THIS HORRIFIC
CRIME, SOMEONE TO THANK HIM FOR
DOING THAT AND LETTING US USE
THAT DATA IN THE BILL THAT WE
PASSED MY COLLEAGUES THAT SPOKE,
UM FROM BALDWIN PARK AND, UM
AND, UM, FROM THE BAY AREA. THIS
THE CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
HELP, AND FOR EVERYBODY THAT
AUTHORED CO AUTHORED AND
SUPPORTED SB 14 AGAIN FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART. I DON'T
THINK IF IT WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
NOT GOTTEN OFF THE SENATE FLOOR
UNANIMOUS. LESLIE. WE WOULD NOT
BE IN A POSITION THAT WE WERE TO
FIGHT WHERE WE NEEDED TO FIGHT
ON THE GREEN CARPET. AND I JUST
THANK YOU ALL FOR THAT. I THANK
YOU FOR HONORING THOSE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS AND THOSE
THAT ARE STILL WRAPPED UP IN
THIS HORRIFIC, DARK UNDERWORLD.
THERE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE. I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT
WHEN SP 14 STARTED AGAIN LAST
YEAR THAT IT ENCOMPASSED
EVERYBODY, ANYBODY AND IT WAS
ONE OF THE HARDEST THING I HAD
TO DO TO GO TO JENNA MCKAY AND
SAY, BECAUSE YOU WERE 18 YOU
DON'T MATTER. UM AND IT DOESN'T
IT JUST BECAUSE YOU WERE 18, AND
SHE WAS TAKEN TO VEGAS, AND IT
TOOK HER A LONG TIME TO GET OUT
OF VEGAS. AND THAT WAS ONE OF
THE HARDEST THINGS I'VE EVER HAD
TO DO, AND I WANT THE PEOPLE IN
THIS HORRIFIC, DARK UNDERWORLD
TO KNOW THAT THEY MATTER AND
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE DECISIONS
TO HELP GET THEM OUT OF THIS
SITUATION AND PROVIDE THEM. WITH
RESOURCES AND I REALIZED WEREN'T
A BUDGET DEFICIT, BUT THERE HAS
TO BE SOMETHING OUT THERE TO
WRAP AROUND SERVICES BECAUSE NO
ONE KNOWS HOW TO DEAL WITH THESE
TRAUMA, AND I THINK THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE THIS LIVED
EXPERIENCE ARE THE BEST RESOURCE
WE COULD EVER ASK FOR. IN ORDER
TO DEFUSE A LOT OF THIS. I WANT
TO THANK YOU AGAIN. MY COLLEAGUE
BRIEFLY AND I KNOW I'M GOING ON
BUT MENTIONED FAMILIAR
TRAFFICKING. WE HAD A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. SOME SYMPOSIUM WE
HEARD SOMEBODY SAY MY SISTER AND
I WERE TRAFFIC. SHE DIDN'T MAKE
IT OUT ALIVE. I WAS TRAFFICKED
WHEN I WAS 18. THIS HAPPENED.
THIS HAPPENED AND THEN THE LAST
LADY THAT SPOKE OPHELIA. SHE
SAID. MY HUMAN TRAFFICKING WAS
DIFFERENT. MY SISTER TRAFFICKED
ME AND THE HARDEST THING I HAD
TO DO WAS TO GO HAVE DINNER AND
SAY, PASS THE POTATOES WHEN I
KNEW WHAT SHE JUST MADE ME DO,
AND I COULDN'T TELL MY PARENTS.
THAT'S A HARD PILL TO SWALLOW.
AND SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED. WE STARTED LAST YEAR
PROTECTING CHILDREN, 0 TO 17.
WE'RE BRINGING IT FORTH JANUARY
WITH SCR 97 TO MAKE IT AWARE TO,
YOU KNOW, RE ENGAGE IN THE
AWARENESS PROCESS, AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES WHO
SUPPORTED SP 14 LAST YEAR AND
WHO CO AUTHORED IN THEIR
SUPPORTING SCR 97. THANK YOU.
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION FOR UTILIZING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT? UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. I'M SORRY. SAYING
NONE ICE 37 AYE. IS 38 NO. ZERO
THE MEASURES THAT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER 92. SENATOR LEHMAN.
PLEASE PLEASE READ Ó. UM PAST
TEMPORARILY MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER 93 SENATOR DIED. HE IS.
PREPARED. PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 94 BY
SENATOR DODD RELATIVE TO DATA
PRIVACY WEEK. SENATOR DODD. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. S C. R. 94
WITH DESIGNATE THE FOURTH WEEK
OF JANUARY IS DATA PRIVACY WEEK
IN THE LAST SUNDAY OF JANUARY'S
DATA PRIVACY DAY, AS ONLINE
ACTIVITIES BECOME INCREASINGLY
PREVALENT IN OUR LIVES.
BUSINESSES AND SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS AMASSED SUBSTANTIAL
PERSONAL DATA WHICH CAN LEAD US
ALL, UH, SO VULNERABLE TO DATA
BREACHES. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT, WHICH I CO
AUTHORED PROVIDES THE STRONGEST
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IN THE U. S
BUT PRIVACY ISSUES REMAIN. TO
KICK OFF THE WEEK TO CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY PROTECTION AGENCY JUST
LAUNCHED A NEW WEBSITE PROVINCE.
PRIVACY DOT C A DOT GOV AS A ONE
STOP SHOP FOR CONSUMERS TO
ACCESS PRIVACY RIGHTS AND TOOLS
WITH THIS SCR WILL BRING
CONTINUED ATTENTION TO THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND HELP
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S PRIVACY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU ALL
RISEN STRONG SUPPORT, AND IT WAS
A CORE AUTHOR. AND I COMMEND THE
CENTER FROM NAPA FOR INTRODUCING
THIS RESOLUTION. SARAH JUST MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT DATA PRIVACY IS
A CRUCIAL PART OF EVERYDAY LIFE.
WE ALMOST UNDERSTAND, UM, HOW
VULNERABLE WE ARE AND THAT THERE
ARE DATA BROKERS OUT THERE. BY
DEFINITION. THOSE ARE FOLKS, WE
DO NOT HAVE A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP WITH OVER 500
REGISTERED DATA BROKERS NOW IN
CALIFORNIA, AND THEY COLLECT
THOUSANDS OF PIECES OF
INFORMATION ON EVERYONE OF US.
AND AS A SENATOR REPRESENTING
SILICON VALLEY. I FEEL A
RESPONSIBILITY OBLIGATION TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE, AND I
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE
WORKED ON THIS AS WELL. BASED ON
OUR CURRENT REPORTS OVER 15.4
MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TARGETS
OF CYBER CRIME. IN THE LAST YEAR
, RESULTING ESTIMATED 10.2
BILLION. DOLLARS OF COST
EVERYDAY PEOPLE AND AGAIN WHERE
DO FOLKS GET ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION? UM OFTENTIMES IT'S
FROM THESE DATA BROKERS WHO
AGAIN WHO HAVE COLLECTED
INFORMATION ON ALL OF US, EVEN
THOSE WHO AREN'T UM THEMSELVES.
NEGATIVE ACTORS ARE CAN BE
VICTIMS OF DATA BREACHES. UH
THEN AGAIN, OUR INFORMATION IS
OUT THERE. CALIFORNIA IS LEADING
THE WAY AS RESOLUTION POINTS OUT
. WE CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY PROTECTION AGENCY. WHICH
SAFEGUARDS THE PRIVACY RIGHTS OF
ALL PEOPLE IN THE STATE. AND
LAST YEAR WE PASSED IT DELETE
ACT, WHICH I AUTHORED THAT WILL
ALLOW ANYONE TO GO TO ONE STOP
SHOP, SPEND 30 SECONDS AND
DELETE THEIR INFORMATION FROM
THESE OVER 500 DATA BROKERS WHO
BUY AND SELL INFORMATION ON
EVERY ONE OF US. SO THERE ARE
THINGS WE CAN DO TO PROTECT
OURSELVES NOW, UM AND I THINK
WITH THE ADVENT OF A I WE'RE
GOING TO DO EVEN MORE TO PROTECT
OURSELVES. UH AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS AND
THAT'S WHY I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SCR 94 TODAY ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING NONE. SENATOR DODD, YOU
MAY CONCLUDE, RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SAYING NONE
EYES 38 NO. ZERO THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MOVING BACK TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER 92 SENATOR LEHMAN IS
PREPARED. PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION 53 BY SENATOR LEHMAN
RELATIVE TO SCHOOL GOVERNANCE ON
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION 53, WHICH RECOGNIZES
THE MONTH OF JANUARY AS SCHOOL
BOARD RECOGNITION MONTH TO
HIGHLIGHT THE DEDICATION AND
HARD WORK OF SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS ARE
ADVOCATES FOR COMMUNITIES,
MAKING THEM A KEY ELEMENT TO OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. THEY ARE
ALSO COMMITTED TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THE NEEDS AND
THEY WORK EVERY DAY TO SUPPORT
AND ADVANCE THE WORK OF ALL
FACULTY STAFF AND STUDENTS ALIKE
. CALIFORNIA HAS NEARLY 1000
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THROUGHOUT
THE STATE, REPRESENTED BY NEARLY
5000 SCHOOL BOARD, MAKE MEMBERS
MAKING THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF LOCALLY
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN OUR STATE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
SERVED ON SCHOOL BOARDS. THE
SENATOR FROM SANTA MONICA
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE, THE
SENATOR FROM HEALDSBURG AND THE
SENATOR FROM YUCAIPA, I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR SERVICE
, EVERY SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AND
ENSURE THAT THEY KNOW THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZES THEIR HARD WORK AND
CONTRIBUTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
RESOLUTION? SEEING NONE. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SAYING NONE
. I 38 NO. ZERO THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. REMEMBER THAT
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
SENATE THIRD READING, WE'RE
GOING TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR UMBERG. AND
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. I
RISE TO HONOR THE LIFE AND
LEGACY OF THE SAN SEBASTIAN, WHO
PASSED AWAY LAST OCTOBER AT HOME
IN COSTA MESA. SHE WAS ONLY 50
YEARS OLD. THE SAME WAS BORN ON
JULY 28TH 1973 AD HOC HOSPITAL.
SHE IS THE DAUGHTER OF JANET AND
JAMES, KNOWN TO ALL OF US AS
WALKIE RAY AND THE NIECE OF
MICHAEL AND TEDDY RAY. SAYING
GRADUATED FROM CORONA DEL MAR
CORONA DEL MAR HIGH SCHOOL IN
1991 WENT ON DURING A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN MARINE SCIENCE FROM
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO. SHE
BEGAN HER CAREER AT THE OCEAN
INSTITUTE IN DANA POINT AS AN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS INSTRUCTOR.
HER NEWFOUND PASSION FOR
EDUCATION LETTER PEPPERDINE
UNIVERSITY WHERE SHE RECEIVED
HER TEACHING CREDENTIAL. BUT
SINCE TEACHING CAREER TOOK HER
TO SEVERAL SCHOOLS IN ORANGE
COUNTY, INCLUDING ORANGE MAGNET
SCHOOL, DAVIS SCHOOL RACE SCHOOL
, KAISER SCHOOL, WHERE SHE
SERVED AS THE SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY, ENGINEERING AND MATH
TEACHER WITH BOUNDLESS ENERGY
AND ENTHUSIASM, SHE MADE SCIENCE
AND ENGAGING IN FUN SUBJECT FOR
COUNTLESS ORANGE COUNTY
STUDENTS. THE SAND WAS NOT ONLY
A DEDICATED TEACHER, BUT SHE WAS
ALSO AN EXCEPTIONAL ATHLETE. SHE
WAS A NATURAL SWIMMER. THEIR
LOVE FOR THE WATER WAS EVIDENT
FROM AN EARLY AGE SHE SWAM
COMPETITIVELY WAS ACCEPTED THAT
JUNIOR OLYMPIC SWIM TEAM AND HER
SENIOR YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL, SHE
DISCOVERED HER PASSION FOR
ROWING AND CONTINUED. A ROWING
JOURNEY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN
DIEGO, WHERE SHE EARNED A SPOT
ON THE VARSITY TEAM. AS A
FRESHMAN. THE SAME DEDICATION
COMMITMENT ALLOWED HER TO ROW
FOR ALL FOUR YEARS IN COLLEGE.
AFTER GRADUATION, SHE EXPLORED
VARIOUS SPORTS SUCH AS RUNNING
MOUNTAIN BIKING AND CROSSFIT,
BUT HER HEART TRULY BELONGS TO
THE OCEAN. THIS LETTER TO
HAWAIIAN OUTRIGGER CANOE RACING
WHERE SHE FOUND HER JOHANNA AND
HER HOME. IT WAS IN THIS SPORT
THAT SHE MET HER LOVING HUSBAND,
RICK, AND FORGE FRIENDSHIPS WITH
TEAMMATES ENDURED FOR OVER 20
YEARS. IN ADDITION TO HER CAREER
IN ATHLETIC PURSUITS, THE SAND
WAS DEEPLY INVOLVED IN VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS AND CLUBS THAT
REFLECTED HER LOVE FOR SCIENCE
AND OCEAN. SHE WAS A PASSIONATE
WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT
CONSERVATION ENERGY EFFORTS AND
HAD A GENUINE LOVE FOR MARINE
LIFE THAT I THINK WILL ONE DAY
BE REFLECTED THE DISCOVERY
SCIENCE CENTER. HER DEDICATION
TO THESE CAUSES WAS AN
INSPIRATION TO ALL WHO KNOW HER.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND,
RICK, HER TWO CHILDREN, BRADLEY
AND SAGE. THE SAND IS ALSO
SURVIVED BY HER PARENTS. SISTER
SARAH, HER BROTHERS, MATTHEW.
DAVID ALEX. I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF THE SAN
MARIE SEBASTIAN. THANK YOU.
PLEASE BRING HER NAME TO THE
FRONT DESK SO SHE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE. IT IS WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF LINDA
CARE. WHY NEW VERY CLOSELY. UM
SHE WAS A PREVIOUS CITY CLERK IN
THE CITY OF BALDWIN PARK, AND I
TOOK OVER YEARS LATER, AND I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO SHARE WORDS
WITH HER AND GET HER GUIDANCE.
LINDA ALWAYS HAD THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE RESIDENTS OF
BOLAND PARK IN MIND. SHE WAS
ALWAYS IMPROVING OUR COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND PRIORITIZING
TRANSPARENCY AND EFFICIENCY IN
THAT OFFICE. SHE PLAYED AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN RESOLVING A
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT IN THE
CITY'S GENERAL FUND, IN GREATLY
CONTRIBUTED TO LEADING ON KEY
ISSUES AND PROGRAMS, INCLUDING
THE ANNUAL SNOW FEST EVENT. I
REMEMBER WHEN SHE RETIRED, THE
CITY WANTED TO RECOGNIZE HER
ACHIEVEMENTS IN YEARS OF PUBLIC
SERVICE AND EVERYTHING SHE'S
DONE FOR OUR COMMUNITY. THIS LED
TO THE BALL AND PARK CITY
COUNCIL DECLARING MARCH 5TH. 23
AS LINDA GARDEZ. SHE WILL BE
SORELY MISSED BY THE RESIDENTS
OF ALLEN PARK AND BY HER FAMILY.
OF THREE CHILDREN, FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND 11 GREAT GRAND
CHILDREN AS A TESTAMENT TO THE
PROFOUND LOVE SHE SHARED WITH
HER LATE HUSBAND, ROBERT. SHE
REQUESTED TO JOIN HIM AND HAVING
HER ASHES SCATTERED AT SEA.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME TODAY
AND ADJOINING IN MEMORY OF LINDA
CARE. THANK YOU. PLEASE BRING
HER NAME FORWARD TO THE DEATH SO
THAT SHE MAY BE MEMORIALIZED BY
THE STATE SENATE. SENATOR DODD.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS, BETTY
RUTH VON ROADS PASSED AWAY ON
TUESDAY, JANUARY 9TH 2024 97
YEARS OF AGE. AFTER FULFILLING A
JOURNEY AS A MOTHER, BETTY BEGAN
HER ADVOCACY JOURNEY IN INTO
AGING POLICY AT THE AGE OF 1619
AT THE AGE OF 63. WHEN I AS A
NAPA COUNTY SUPERVISOR APPOINTED
HER TO THE COMMISSION ON AGING.
SHE NOT ONLY SERVED ON THE
COMMISSIONER AGING BUT ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE NAPA
SOLANO AREA AGENCY ON AGING, A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEADERSHIP ALLIANCE, SHE WORKED
ON THE NAPA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ELDER ABUSE PLANNING
PREVENTION COUNCIL AND WAS AN
ADVOCATE HERE IN SACRAMENTO ON
BEHALF OF MANY ELDERLY
CALIFORNIANS. AND DUE TO DEBT.
BETTY'S DILIGENCE. SHE IS ALSO
KNOWN FOR HER NAPA COUNTY
CAREGIVING ORDINANCE,
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST BACKGROUND.
UM, MANDATE, BACKGROUND CHECK
MANDATE FOR CAREGIVERS OF SENIOR
RESIDENTS. IN FACT, WHEN I WAS
ON THE BOARD, WE NAMED THAT LAW
BETTY'S LAW. IN AN ADMIRATION
FOR ALL THE WORK SHE DID TO GET
IT THERE. BETTY LIVED A GREAT
LIFE, ONE OF SERVICE, HUMILITY
AND DEDICATION. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF
BETTY ROADS. THANK YOU. SENATOR
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FORWARD TO
THE FRONT DESK SO WE CAN
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZE HER.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS,
SENATOR GROVE, THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES AND THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
330 PM THIS AFTERNOON. AT THEN,
AT THAT POINT IN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN WILL BE MADE. WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT 9 A.M.
HAVE A GREAT FEW DAYS. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
330 AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED, AND WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT 9 A.M.